We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
More and more people asking about moving out
of the country.
Take a listen to this.
Hi, David.
So I've been so terrified of the possibility
of Trump getting another four years that I've
been thinking pretty seriously about how I
would try to the country lead the USA and
live in a different country if that were to
happen.
Yeah, I just think I would be safer.
So I'm wondering if you have any advice or
people who want to do that.
Do you remember anything about your own immigration
from Argentina that bribe useful to somebody
who was thinking about immigrating away from
the United States?
Well, yes.
What I remember is that there is a reason
why most people don't do it.
We he we you know, we've heard many times
before, if Bush gets reelected, I move to
Canada.
If Obama gets reelected, I'm moving.
I don't know where they would go.
But in any case, most people don't do it because
it's insane.
I mean, it's real.
It's really a difficult thing.
It's as someone who came to the United States
still young enough to quickly learn the language
and culture.
It is a really big thing to abandon your home.
And this is why, you know, we shouldn't take
lightly the fact that people are willing to
come to the United States, even illegally.
Understand the cataclysmic change that this
represents from them.
It is an an unimaginable change.
And I would be lying if I said I'm thinking
of relocating permanently if Donald Trump
gets reelected.
But the truth is that it is, and particularly
now with the mobile studio where I can basically
take have the exact same sound and video quality
no matter where I go.
I am certainly thinking of if Trump gets reelected,
we'll be here covering the lame duck period.
And of course, the the reelection the inauguration,
rather.
But I am looking at spending some months doing
the show from somewhere else.
And I understand that not everybody can do
that.
Not everybody's jobs are mobile.
Not everybody can afford it.
But it is something I am looking at just to
get a break, just to get get get a break from
being in a place where constantly just idiocy
is happening.
So I think that very few people are really
going to move out of the United States if
Trump is reelected, partially because it's
really cataclysmic change in one's life, partially
because it's really hard to do it.
You can't just move to a lot of the places
that I think most Americans would look to
move to if they are trying to avoid Donald
Trump.
But certainly I'd be lying if if if I said
it's not occurring to me to get a break from
the United States if Donald Trump does get
reelected.
But we'll we're going to continue talking
about that.
And I'm interested in hearing from the audience
about it.
Don't miss today's bonus show.
There's another show for our members.
Membership is our number one funding source.
Grab a membership at join Pacman dot com and
I'll see you on today's bonus show.